Естонія стала першою країною на планеті
яка оголосила цілину геноцидною
без нашої потужної підтримки в
економічному плані військової техніки та
ще більшого болю для Росії через санкції
Україна не зможе вижити
жодна нація в Європі не може спокійно
спати вночі до поки режим Путіна при
владі в Кремлі
побачити як Володимир Путін піде у
в'язницю у пекло зі мною гурмас Рейн
сало Міністр закордонних справ Естонії
Дякую що приділили час сьогодні вранці
ви аплодували Німеччині За поставки
Україні системи ППО айрістей Німеччина
прокинулась ні комплексно-західна
спільнота зробила недостатньо ця ціна
оплачена круглі українців мій посил
чіткий наші запаси зброї невичерпані
зокрема важке озброєння Про яке просили
українське друзі а також боєприпаси і
Росія зараз навмисно знищує цивільну
інфраструктуру перед настанням зими щоб
уникнути ще однієї Гірники варто діяти і
надати Україні конкретний
протиповітряний захист у широкому сенсі
тож я вітаю сміливий крок Німеччини це
також хороший сигнал тому що щойно
канцлер Німеччини оголосив про це кілька
днів потому зброя була доставлена в
Україну І тому мій посил Ми повинні
негайно підняти нашу планку негайно
країни Балтії від початку критикували
Німеччину за те що вона недостатньо
робить для військової підтримки України
Ваша країна Естонія з розрахунку на душу
населення надала приблизно в 10 разів
більше допомоги ніж Німеччина хоча більш
як удвічі бідніше що ви думаєте про це
Я думаю що наша аргументація чому ми це
робимо має за собою резон і серце серце
- це справді моральне відчуття що
цивільних українців Україну її народ
потрібно захищати у нинішньому контексті
це єдиний найефективніший спосіб зробити
це друга складова раціональне розуміння
що діяти швидко - це найпривніший шлях
якомога швидше завершити цю війну тому
що зараз якщо ми подивимося як діяла
Західна спільнота дії в основному були
постфактум наприклад коли Путін щось
зробив тоді як відповідь на це були нові
хвилі поставок зброї та нові хвилі
санкцій моя мета змінити таку парадигму
щоб ми справді серцем і практичними
поставками інвестували в українську
перемогу а це означає не реагувати на те
до яких конкретних кроків вдається Путін
а просто дати достатньо зброї та підняти
Санкції до такого болючого рівня щоб це
припинило війну щоб Путіну так припекло
але на жаль цього ще не трапилося
дату у вашій країні проголосували за те
щоб назвати Росію терористичною державою
що це означає Я маю на увазі як це може
змінити сприйняття Україною того що
робить захід коли ви змінюєте наратив
змінюєте формулювання
Я вважаю це дуже важливо тому що на
початку було слово якщо цитувати Біблію
і тому я думаю що таке формулювання того
що відбувається є важливим фундаментом
для вчинення дій Естонія стала також
першою країною на планеті яка оголосила
цю війну геноцидною я склав цей текст я
спілкувався з багатьма експертами з
міжнародного права я спілкувався з
представниками потерпілих І тому ми є
послання чітке намір Путіна полягає в
тому щоб знищити одну націю це основний
намір і всі дії в цій геноцидній війні
показують що їх можна описати статтями
конвенції проти геноциду деякі партії чи
особи на захо уникають цього опису
кажучи що це може призвести до ескалації
справді ця конвенція її остання абзац
говорить що якщо держава-учасниці
виявлять факт геноциду вони повинні
боротися з ним а дехто каже що це може
призвести до ескалації але моя відповідь
що значить це може призвести до
ескалації якщо геноцид уже відбувається
йдеться вже навіть не про українську
війну не про цих конкретних людей які
гинуть це перевірка нашої людяності того
ким ми є нинішнє покоління європейців
які так хордо заявляють і говорять про
цінності тепер питання втім ким ми є
насправді ми можемо бути людьми на яких
онуки озиратимуться як на сміливців або
ми можемо зазнати моральної поразки і
тоді соромно буде дивитися на себе в
дзеркало можливо через деякий час
Ви також закликали до створення
міжнародного трибуналу для злочинів
агресії для того щоб притягти Володимира
Путіна і його соратників до
відповідальності Чого бракує нинішній
системі правосуддя яку роль буде
виконувати цей новий трибунал
нинішня система кримінальної
відповідальності міжнародна від
компетенцію міжнародного кримінального
суду не охоплює конкретно цю свого роду
колиску злочинів проти людяності
організацію війни натискання кнопки коли
верховний лідер заявляє про початок
загарбницької війни після чого всі
звірства втілюються в життя Отже якщо ми
зазирнемо в минуле рішенням було
створити спеціальні судові колеги
трибунали от Хок які також могли б
розглядати ці злочини зокрема злочини
агресії скоєний Путіним та вищим
керівництвом
Як ви оцінюєте цю різницю з прийнятті
загрози що йде від Росії у країнах
Балтії Це здається дуже відчутним тут у
Німеччині Це здається чимось більш
далеким як ви це пояснюєте
[музика]
Таллін розташовані на відносно однаковій
дистанції від Києва справа полягає в
тому що ми є сусідньою країною з Росією
ми справді є певним мисом НАТО тому
варто запровадити комплекси рішень щодо
нового рівня оборони союзників НАТО Ми
отримали додаткові сили від союзників ми
вдячні за це але потрібно ще багато
зробити Ми хотіли би бачити постійний
контингент військ на нашій землі
європейці вже довгий час покладаються на
американців у питанні гарантій безпеки
континенту і зараз багато політиків
починають стверджувати що ми повинні
стати більш суверенними нам потрібно
зміцнити власну оборону в цьому
контексті міністра Юрія де щойно
відписали європейську ініціативу Скай
шілд у короткостроковій перспективі це
не покращить захист Естонії чи Європи
від Російської загрози але Чи очікуєте
Ви що російська загроза триватиме так
довго що вона виправдає всі інвестиції
для створення свого роду залізного
куполу над Європою на реалізацію якого
знадобляться роки
я не роблю політичну некоректний заклик
щодо зміни режиму в Росії але Дозвольте
мені заявити що жодна нація в Європі не
може спокійно спати вночі до поки режим
Путіна при владі в Кремлі
що стосується інвестицій в оборону до
гострокої перспективі та в короткий
перспективі Я вважаю що звичайно нам
потрібно думати щодо більш економічного
підходу до безпеки але зараз Центральна
точка тяжіння справді полягає в тому як
перемогти як підтримати Україну щоб
виграти цю війну тому що без нашої
потужної підтримки в економічному плані
військової техніки та ще більшого болю
для Росії через санкції Україна не зможе
вижити
чи ти як Володимир Путін піде у в'язницю
у пекло
з'явилися повідомлення про які я також
маю спитати вас що Естонія не пускала
українських біженців які намагалися
потрапити до країни через Росію Це
звісно як ви знаєте не відповідає їхнім
правам на притулок незважаючи на те
звідки люди і Звідки вони приїхали Чим
ви обґрунтовуєте цей захід
населення Естонії становить близько
мільйона 300 тисяч осіб ми прийняли
понад 100 тисяч громадян України ми
відмовили можливо одному відсотку від
цього числа і причини були в тому що
щось було не так що вони не відповідали
цим чітким критеріям біженців з України
можливо це були люди які проживали в
Росії задовго до цієї стадії війни що ще
щось подібне що може викликати
занепокоєння щодо безпеки але всі ці
випадки розглядаються звісно гуманно
швидко та на основі індивідуальних
рішень наскільки консервовані тим щоб
Путін збирається перетнути червоні лінії
та застосувати ядерну зброю або
вторгнутися на територію НАТО
Я вважаю що всі європейці повинні
турбуватися про безпеку довкілля та
непередбачуваність Путіна
говорячи про ядерну загрозу Я думаю що
Путін має намір втягнути на це у гру за
допомогою страху проєкт страх Я думаю є
ядром його ескалації з осені і ціль не
українці а західні столиці і в цьому
контексті Я б сказав що ми повинні
пам'ятати покоління наших батьків часів
холодної війни як вони пережили
стримування ядерної загрози яка прийшла
з Радянського Союзу якщо Росія застосує
ядерну зброю або ядерний терор проти
цивільних ядерних об'єктів декількох в
Україні тоді відповідь буде фатальною І
це заявили Білий дім європейські лідери
Але я думаю що зараз не той момент коли
ми повинні говорити про те що в цій
перспективі Путін використовуватиме
ядерну зброю наскільки я пам'ятаю навіть
Сталін не погрожував безпосередньо
ядерною зброєю як робить Путін Сталін
мав більш неодно Німеччині дискусії про
мир у всьому світі та соціалістичні
ідеали Але звичайно ми повинні розуміти
що наша помилка західного світу була
стратегічною що ми сприймали всі ці дії
Росії проти заходу як нубіру окремих
елементів чи то були війни чи то були
терористичні дії чи втручання у вибори
економічна чи політична корупція чи
примус Ні це один великий комплекс з
метою отримати перевагу над заходом і
Путін не приховує свого наміру він
вірить що зможе й дощі до кінця досягти
результату єдиною відповіддю чого він
боїться або не може дестабілізувати є
наша рішучість і політична воля зараз
він інвестує в те щоб ми зламалися і
відповідь така є впевнений що не
зламаємося маю надію бути впевненим
наразі Путін сподівається що ми
зламаємось і він точно сподівається що
дух українців зламається через його
атаки по містах таких як Київ
я говорив з багатьма українцями здійснив
шість візитів в Україну українці не
бояться навіть ядерної атаки не можу
сказати що вони сміються але вони так
говорять українська перспектива Вони
бачать що означає життя за режимом
Путіна Путін навів чудовий приклади що
це означає фізичне знищення і приниження
людської гідності ці випадки траплялися
зі звичайними цивільними які проживають
на окупованих територіях
Чи можу я спитати про цю останню тактику
коли ми бачимо використання Дронів
особливо тих які атакують в містах є
деякі докази що їх постачав Іран Іран це
спростовує А чи ви маєте докази що саме
Іран стоїть за постачаннями цих Дронів і
навіть ракет РФ і наскільки ця зброя
змінює хід війни Ні я сподіваюся Не
змінюю хід війни у військовому сенсі але
це питання до військових експертів Я
вважаю що в цьому випадку стратегічно
дуже важливо щоб європейські Союз захід
чітко відповіли Ірану що це не той
випадок коли ви є автократією чи іншою
країною і можете вважати що отримаєте
політичну економічну вигоду ставши
непрямим чи прямим співучасником у цій
війні підтримуючи військовим способом РФ
це те що я підтримав в Люксембурзі на
зустрічі міністрів закордонних справ
ідею негайного запровадження
обмежувальних заходів щодо Ірану Чи
бачив Я особисто ці безпілотники які
транспортували з тегера на Україну
Відповідь негативна але в цих випадках
Ми повинні покладатися на наших
партнерів також у понеділок Міністр
закордонних справ України дуже чітко
заявив що цей іранський безпілотники
тому країна Європейського Союзу зараз це
обговорюють шукають докази Але я вважаю
що ми маємо діяти негайно міністри Дуже
дякую вам дякую